[Music]
this evenings event is a partnership
with Massey College and I'm delighted to
have that partnership when Master Segal
the master of Massey and I first chatted
about it it seemed like a natural
marriage Massey is all about excellence
it's about research it's about young
people it's about interdisciplinarity
and of course many the the fellows in
Massey come from all over the world and
that pretty well sums up what C farce
all about and so this was this is a
second of the of a series we hope an
annual series of lectures at the nexus
between science and research and society
and how to engage some of the top
researchers not just in Toronto or
Canada or in the world including
tonight's speaker with issues that are
of importance to all of us and that
brings me to see far at sea far we have
believed for over 30 years now that the
best way to tackle really important
questions questions the most exciting
questions of our time and the most
important questions of our time is quite
simple and that as you put the really
the best people in the world in a room
and have them give them the opportunity
to have a sustained and deep
collaboration to address that question
and so that's what we do we have about
400 CFR fellows they come from 18
countries 120 or so institutions roughly
half are Canadian and the other half are
not and they they divided into roughly
14 programs and those programs range
from things like quantum information
science to quantum materials to
economics institutions organizations and
growth artificial intelligence programs
early childhood development evolution of
the cosmos etc and I think the the
validity of that approach has really
been borne out by the success
of our fellows and the programs that
they're in over the last 34 years of
CFR's existence really a lot of the
early thinking about the socio-economic
determinants of health came out of a
very early sea fire program all of deep
learning and artificial intelligence
really started here in Canada at a sea
fire program our understanding of the
evolution of the of our earth snowball
earth hypothesis for example came out of
a sea fire program and I could go on and
on all our 14 children are wonderful
they're all geniuses and they really are
making really profound advances in our
understanding of ourselves our world and
our and our universe it's really a
pleasure to have so many people here and
I mentioned excellence and so I like
bragging about our fellows and the
people associated with them so just
today the Royal Society of Canada
announced their medals for this year and
one of the medalists is Curtis Berlin
get from the University of British
Columbia he's gonna be receiving the
Rutherford medal Ernest Rutherford some
of you may know discovered electrons
when he was at McGill University many
years ago Curtis is in our program
called bio-inspired solar energy and
about half the winners of the Rutherford
medal over the last 20 years have been
see Farr fellows and then it's a real
delight for me to name the the winner of
the Bancroft medal she's here in the
audience with us Barbara Sherwood Lawler
it's something else we share with Massey
College Barbara is a professor here at U
of T the Bancroft medal is given for
outstanding research in geology and
geophysics which Barbara sir knees
accomplished that Barbara is tightly
associated with Massey and she's an
incoming member of the president's
Research Council here at CFR
so congratulations Barbara wherever you
are
so our our speaker tonight Joe Henrik
well I'll say more about Joe in a moment
is a member of our one of our 14
programs it's called institutions
organizations and growth and that
program is trying to address a really
interesting question which is what is it
or why is it that some countries are
very successful are powerful some
countries are are united some countries
are the opposite and we're witnessing
what's going on to our friends to the
south of us at the moment you know we we
laugh at it but you know it's
troublesome and there are issues there
deep deep issues and why is that why is
it that we share the same continent with
the United States we have a different
history but what is it about the United
States that makes it so different from
Canada in so many different ways why is
it that some countries are rich some
countries are poor why is that the some
countries have very strong Democrat
democratic institutions and some don't
and so that program which is made up of
economists historians a political
scientists and anthropologists including
Joe Henrik have been meeting for a
number of years now to really get at
that issue and it's a really important
issue when you're thinking about what's
going on in our planet today so let me
just end by saying a few things about
our speaker tonight Joe Hendrick is is a
distinguished anthropologist he kind of
embodies I think everything about let's
see far stands for excellence he's at
Harvard he was on faculty at UBC for
many years so he's international now
he's interdisciplinary his very first
degree was an aeronautical engineering
and as he said to our group of great
supporters just a few moments ago he
went through the alphabet and stopped at
the A's
so it was aeronautical engineering and
then after apology I hope you have
another joke Joey oh I didn't want to
steal all your jokes Joe's research
focuses on
evolution evolution of what is it that
lies behind our psychological
decision-making culture culture gene
interactions how does that evolve
what does prestige mean in our society
leadership the evolution of complex
institutions in our society and how that
plays out from an anthropological and
biological perspective so he I think
brings are really important and quite
unique perspective not only to see FAR's
program in institutions organizations
and growth but to the world of
scholarship Joe is a professor at
Harvard as I said in the department of
human evolutionary biology anywhere he
runs the Graduate Studies a program he's
the winner of many awards I only
mentioned a couple when he was in Canada
he held a Canada Research Chair in human
evolutionary biology
he's a Killam UBC Prize winner he won
the precedence at the US presidents
early career award for scientists and
engineers and a few others that I could
I could go on Joe's research in the book
that he'll be the from which he'll be
talking about to us this evening it's
really based on trying to understand why
is it to me this is a really you know
such a fundamental question that we tend
not to ask it it's like fish don't ask
about water right why is it that when
humans emerged out of Africa about
50,000 years ago which is actually not
that long ago if you think about it why
is it that we became the dominant
species on the planet certainly from a
biological perspective a purely
biological perspective we you know we're
not big we don't have sharp claws
we don't have fur we don't know how to
swim or fly we have actually none of the
things you would think of a priori that
you need to to dominate from a
biological perspective on this planet
and yes of course without question we
are probably too dominant a species on
this planet and so Joe's book and what
he'll talk to us about this evening is
the secrets of our success Joe Henrik
thank you
very much
[Applause]
thanks to masa college and si far for
organizing this event I'll jump right
into things here so I want to begin by
setting up a puzzle for you and the
puzzle is that how did our species go
from a relatively garden-variety
ape three million years ago to being the
most ecologically dominant species on
the planet and I think to get at this
question we want to go because in the
modern world you know we're a species
that makes aircraft carriers and iPhones
and build massive hydroelectric dams and
even in the ancient world we built
massive tombs and temples and great
walls and grand canals but we want to go
back to a former time before Industrial
Technology or the first cities or towns
back before the origins of Agriculture
even back then you can see that our
species was fundamentally different from
other species so about a hundred
thousand years ago humans begin
expanding Out of Africa and expand into
an immense diversity of environments so
sometime after sixty thousand years ago
humans arrived in Australia and began to
live in the arid deserts of Australia
after about fifty thousand years ago we
expand into the temperate and sometimes
icy forests of Europe after forty
thousand years ago were into the Arctic
and inhabiting the Arctic Siberia the
Siberian Arctic sometime around foot
around the same time humans are an
island Melanesia living in the malarial
swamps of New Guinea and then after
20,000 years ago we enter the new world
and expand into the Neotropics and all
the way down to the tip of Tierra del
Fuego all before the origins of
Agriculture and in this massive
expansion were able to adapt to
different environments and when
anthropologists have studied populations
still living in traditional ways in the
environments they find that they're
incredibly well adapted behaviorally to
life in these places now this is
interesting because when we look at
other species they too are well adapted
to their environments so these are the
kind of bird beaks that inspire Darwin
when he looked at the finches in the
Galapagos but these species are adapting
genetically now one species that can be
particularly informative is the other
ecologically dominant species on earth
so the most ecologically dominant
invertebrate is the ants
but Anstead it the old-fashioned way
they speciated into over 14,000
different species with a dizzying array
of local environment mentally specific
adaptations humans meanwhile are
genetically relatively homogeneous and
especially given our immense diversity
there's hardly any genetic variation and
only a few local spent locally specific
genetic adaptations now I think this
question is often not asks because we
think we already know the answer and the
typical answer is that well we're smart
we have big brain so here you can see on
my slide that that's a human brain
compared to the chimpanzee brain so 3
times the size of a chimpanzee brain and
then we use these big brains to figure
out solve problems so we solve the
problems with intelligence so the first
thing I want to do is try to convince
you that intelligence is not the answer
and that there's a much more powerful
process at work that explains the secret
of our success and so I'm going to begin
by dipping into what my colleagues and I
call the lost European Explorer files
and these are cases in which hapless
European explorers in one case it's a
group of American explorers end up in
some environment - that them feels
hospitable and formidable and that they
struggle to survive so they typically
can't find food travel build shelters
they often end up engaging in
cannibalism they get sick and degree
that they can survive they're depending
on local groups of hunter-gatherers who
have been living there surviving and
often thriving for centuries or even
millennia so I want to give you the case
of Burke and Will's there's a few other
cases and the book each one is
instructive in its own way you may not
have heard of the Burke and Will's case
if you're Australian you certainly have
this is if the year is 1860 and there's
a public-private partnership in
Melbourne that decides once to send an
expedition north and south to the Gulf
of Carpentaria and Robert Burke is
selected to lead the expedition now this
is a fascinating story actually and I
encourage you to read more about it but
I have to make a long story short so
Burke and Will's have 12 weeks of food
at one point and they send out an
advance party of four men with 12 weeks
of food and they head up to the Gulf of
Carpentaria after eight weeks they
arrive at the Gulf or they leave
get close enough they can smell the salt
air and the salty water and so they
declare victory and turn around things
go poorly they have to start eating
their pack animals and at one point they
had imported some camels from India
because they thought the camels would do
well in the desert some of their camels
escaped
they eventually dragged into Cooper's
Creek which is only half way so Cooper's
Creek is there and the supply team that
was going to resupply them has left and
they have to decide whether they're
going to try to catch the supply team or
make another choice they end up making
the other choice they get resupplied at
this point and burke decides instead to
head to follow Cooper's Creek and go
west to a ranch and police post that's a
150 miles away now the ranch and police
posts are a place that's prophetically
named mount hopeless so they begin
heading for mountain hopeless and
relatively early on in their trip along
the Cooper's Creek their last camel gets
stuck in the mud it died and dies so now
they're effectively marooned along
Cooper's Creek because without the camel
to transport water they can't travel the
last stretch after Cooper's Creek ends
to the ranch and police post so they
have to start trying to survive as
hunter-gatherers along Cooper's Creek
now they can't find food they can't seem
to hunt they try fishing that doesn't
work but it looks like they might be
able to survive because they're getting
occasional gifts of fish from the yuan
true tribe that's the hunter-gatherers
that have inhabited the region for eons
going back sixty thousand years and why
they're in one of the you'll want
through Kip camps they notice women
processing this sporocarp they call it a
seed and it's this as this crops called
Nardo now they're able to then grind up
the nardoo and be able to make bread and
gruel and muffin so it looks like
they're going to get be able to get
enough calories the problem was when
they are in the elantra villages they
didn't notice that there's a complex
processing that there that the women of
the community put the Nardo through so
they grind it leach it heat it and then
only eat it with a mussel shell or they
grind it leach it and bake it in ash and
this is crucial because Nardo has an
enzyme called fami
which depletes the body's vitamin b1 and
you'll get a horrible disease called
berry berry
so Burke and Will's are consuming lots
of this Nardo and it's giving them a
full stomach but it's toxic and
indigestible unless properly processed
so they end up poisoning and starving to
death why they're trying to camp out
alone Cooper's Creek this is a it's
actually score sad but fascinating to
read because wills was writing in his
diary like a good Victorian right down
to close to the last day and he's sort
of describing this the experience that
he's going through the third member of
their group his name is king
stumbles off delirious into the outback
and is rescued by the Elan true where he
stays until another party comes from
Melbourne and and we have part of the
story from from King now this example is
important because Burke and Will's
couldn't figure out how to survive as
hunter-gatherers and many scholars have
argued that human minds actually evolved
in a world of hunter-gatherers so if
there's one thing our brains should be
good at its surviving as
hunter-gatherers we spent millions of
years as hunter-gatherers yet when push
comes to shove were terrible at
surviving as hunter-gatherers it's worth
noting that Youmans have lived in
Australia for sixty thousand years as
hunter-gatherers Burke and Will's
couldn't figure out how to do it they
couldn't find food water they couldn't
make tools now one other thing they
might have eaten was the Moreton Bay
Chestnut but of course yeah you probably
don't know this but that would have also
poisoned them so lots of the foods that
hunter-gatherer populations rely on are
poisonous and less properly processed so
there's a lot of know-how another plant
they probably ran across but didn't know
how to use was spinifex
so this is a kind of unobtrusive it
doesn't look like a particularly useful
plan but there are small crystals on the
leaves of this plan which when knocked
off and combined with kangaroo dung
apparently other dongs aren't as
effective and then heated it makes a
powerful adhesive that you can use for
making tools now so
the reason they couldn't survive is
because they didn't get the inheritance
of this kind of knowledge this
non-genetic body of information that
humans require to survive as a
hunter-gatherer even in a place where
we've survived for fifty thousand years
now you might say well Joe that's you're
just putting too high highest standard
there's no way
any animal could survive which if
they're just dropped into the Australian
outback remember I mentioned the camels
well those camels escaped and if you
know anything about the Australian
outback you'll know that there's
thousands and thousands of feral camels
now in the Australian outback the camels
survive the lost European explorer tests
camels have innate taste cues which
allow them to zero in on plants that are
good for them and good for them to eat
they have powerful digestive systems
that detoxify plants in a way that human
digestive systems don't and are very
susceptible to poisons and of course
they have a sense of smell that allows
them to find water even up to a mile
away so other animals can can pass the
European explorer test now let me come
at this from another angle this is a set
of experiments a battery of cognitive
tests that Esther Hermann Mike Tomasello
and their colleagues administered to
three different aged species so
orangutangs the Asian ape
chimpanzees are closest relative from
tropical Africa and humans and in fact
they admit they specifically
administered it to two and a half year
old humans so this is my son Josh he's
my representative two and a half year
old human and there was 18 different
tests here and they can be divided up
into tests about space quantities
causality and then social learning and
here you see the results so the vertical
axis is the percentage of correct
answers for each species now these were
incentivized tests so all three species
quite like snacks and when you pass the
test you got a snack and so it's highly
motivating to all these species now
you'll you'll notice that the humans
performed about as well as the chimps in
space
the chimps did slightly better we
couldn't distinguish that statistically
if we tried but slightly better same
thing in causality and in fact in one of
the causality sub tests is about tool
using the chimps
the two and a half year olds they do
much better now the place where you see
the big division is social learning
chimps are described by developmental
psychologists as imitation machines
they're just looking out into the world
and they're drinking in the behavior and
the expressions and all kinds of things
from those in their social milieu apes
are better than lots of species but
they're terrible at this stuff compared
to humans and in fact this experiment
the they had to do a lot of pilot work
in order to find an experiment where the
the other Apes weren't at floor and the
kids weren't at ceiling so this is an
imitation test that the other apes are
particularly good at now in the book I
document other comparisons between
chimps and in this case undergrads so
chimps are able to compete with
undergrads on tests of working memory
and on tests of strategic thinking in
which economists can calculate what the
optimal behavior is what the Nash
equilibrium is shims zero right in on
the Nash human systematically miss it
and they in the book I described reasons
why they might systematically miss it
that it has to do with her their
tendency to copy others which in which
messes them up now importantly here if
we put adult humans into this into these
tests the adult humans would blow the
roof off the test so there would be no
competition between the adult humans so
humans continue to improve their
cognitive abilities from age two and a
half up to a third decade of life right
and some some cognitive abilities
continue to get better but the Apes are
as good as they're going to get at about
five years old so that's when chimp
stopped nursing so it's when they stop
being infants they're not getting better
so they're plateaued so the secret of
our ability to solve these cognitive
tests lies in the download of
information that we acquire during
maturation which which these other Apes
don't get I'll say more about that in a
minute so the case that I'm making is
that it's not about our intelligence
that explains our species ecological
dominance but it's in fact about our
cultural abilities about the fact that
we're really good at copying from others
that thing we don't let kids do when
they're in school copy off their
neighbor turns out to be the secret of
our success and essential to making that
work as our sociality so we need to be
interconnected with others so
information flows among minds and that's
what really generates powerful
innovation and adaptive cumulative
cultural evolution
this is the concept I called a
collective brain and when you begin to
build mathematical models of humans
using the actual learning tools that we
use you find out that a robust result
from this work is that larger and more
interconnected populations or to
generate fancier tools better technology
and more adaptive repertoires and then
finally the case I'll make towards the
end of today's talk is that this has
been going on for a long time that this
body of non genetic information has been
shaping human genetic evolution and that
the products of this called human of
cultural process have been some of the
major forces that have shaped our
anatomy physiology and psychology now to
really understand this it's important to
realize why this kind of approach hasn't
been popular before so a little bit of
sociology of these approaches so for a
long time people have been trying to
apply evolutionary approaches to human
behavior the problem is this work has
been bedeviled
by an intellectually destructive
dichotomy between nature and nurture
between explanations based on genetic
evolution which people call biology
natural selection versus explanations
based on learning or on culture or these
other kinds of mechanisms so it ended up
in this competition and that that debate
didn't go very far or I should say has
been unproductive when on what I'm
advocating here is what we need to do is
use the logic of natural selection and
recognize that our capacities for
culture are themselves products of
natural selection so our brains are
evolved but they're evolved not for
solving food share of finding food tasks
in environments in which
hunter-gatherers involved but for
acquiring information from others
because that's where all the information
that you need is and that's what what
Burke and Will's did insufficiently well
then the other idea is that this then
feeds back on shapes our genetic
evolution so I'll say more about that in
a few minutes now I want to give you a
brief sense of how we how we do this so
how do we think about our learning
capacities as products of natural
selection what you want to think about
is how should our minds filter the world
so what kinds of information should we
pay attention to in the world when
should we use cultural evolution versus
relying on our own in
stinks our own experience and who should
we pay attention to so who in our social
milieu is likely to have adaptive
information that might be useful to us
later on so some cues that are generated
by this theoretical approach but we also
now know are empirically found in young
children in infants even and in adults
so young children and adults rely on
cues of skill or competence so how well
someone does someone so in a
hunter-gatherer society you tend to copy
those whose arrows tend to hit their
prey success is an aggregated technique
so in a hunter-gatherer society you
would copy the person who brings back to
the most prey or is the most prolific we
also know that young children also use
cues of prestige as do adults these are
second order cues so you're using
prestige when you're watching who other
people are attending to and deferring to
and you preferentially learn from those
individuals it's a way of exploiting the
fact that others are knowledgeable about
who is worthy of paying attention to we
know that young children even when they
have knowledge about competence or
success will often still weigh the age
of the other individual so children can
use age as a way of scaffolding themself
up to increasingly complex skills so if
we take my hunter-gatherer five-year-old
and he wants to become a good hunter he
could focus on the best hunter in the
community who's probably between 36 and
40 or what's that Hunter's probably
likely to have skills and abilities that
exceed the ability of the five-year-old
to learn he's wiser to pay attention to
the most skilled and successful
seven-year-old and then when he's seven
he can pay attention to the 9 year old
or the 10 year old so he can scaffold
his skills up the other way that age is
important is that the most senior
members of the community are have a
lifetime of experience and they've also
had a lifetime to learn from others
that's one reason why they might be
useful as people to learn from another
reason and this one is more subtle and
potentially more important as a natural
selection has been acting not everybody
gets to be old so by the time you're
looking at the generation 60 or 70 a
whole bunch of people have been plucked
out and if with the practices that
people use in their lifetime affect
their likelihood of getting plucked out
then they're no longer in that pool and
that creates a kind of
general advantage finally there's good
reason to believe that humans use cues
of self-similarity so you need to
acquire those skills abilities
motivations ways of thinking ways of
doing that are going to be useful to you
and the roles you're likely to use later
in life so many anthropologists argue
that the division of labor between males
and females is old and something I'll
come back to old in the human lineage
something I'll come back to in a few
minutes
if that's true then males should be
biased to copy males and females to copy
females because that makes you more
likely to get those bits of cultural
information of ways of behaving of
motivations of skills likely to be
useful to you later in life the same
thing applies to other kinds of
self-similarity
and we now know from lots of research in
psychology that's been done over decades
that humans are cultural learners an
immense variety of domains so food
preferences made choices technological
adoptions one fun one if you have
children is food choice if you tell your
kids what they they should eat that
doesn't really work but if you seat them
at a table with slightly older kids who
match them on sex the kids will learn to
eat whatever those kids eat and there's
lots of fun psychological experiments
showing that so you have to make deals
with your your co-parent or your other
parents another interesting one is
suicide so in a celebrity a prestigious
person commits suicide there's often a
ripple of suicides that can spread out
from that and it often matches along
these kind of cue lines so people match
on ethnicity they match on sex as well
lots of other domains and these develop
early there's evidence for them in
one-year-olds their automatic and
unconscious we're doing it all the time
without realizing it so now we have this
set of psychological capacities we can
interact and learn from other and the
information is filtered by this
selective attention to some individuals
and some kinds of information over
others and this will produce
unconsciously and outside people's
awareness cultural adaptations
behavioral repertoires
that are well adapted to the environment
and I just have time to give you one
example and it's one you're familiar
with please partially so humans do this
odd thing which to our foods we often
add spices now spices vary and there's
lots of different kinds
spices but often they're chemicals that
plants produce that are meant to kill
fungi or bacteria or keep other animals
like mammals away and humans add these
to their foods it provides no
nutritional or caloric value but we like
to add them now researchers studying
this have noticed that spices tend to be
things that kill pathogens they tend in
fact the most commonly used spices are
garlic and onions and they're the most
effective at killing bacteria and
pathogens on meat and if you look at
across societies and you analyze
cookbooks you find that in hotter
climates societies use combinations of
spices that are more antimicrobial now
of course people don't eat spices
especially in hot places because they
think they're going to kill pathogens
but recipes have evolved over time so
that they do kill pathogens and they
make food that wouldn't otherwise be
healthy healthier and this is an example
of the unconscious learning process I
particularly like Chili Peppers as an
example because the capsaicin and Chili
Peppers evolved to keep mammals away
humans are innately aversive to
capsaicin babies don't like it chimps
won't eat it but humans can learn to
enjoy the pain that capsaicin actually
taps a pain Channel learn to enjoy the
pain that it induces one of our tricks
is we can turn pain into pleasure to
other things you could read about in the
book one is the nixtamalization which of
the practices of using ash or Burns
seashells in corn mix and this saves
people who are dependent on corn as a
staple from a horrible disease called
pellagra but the people who put ash from
their fire into the corn don't know that
it's releasing the otherwise unavailable
niacin and saving them from pellagra
turns out to be a very hard thing to
figure out okay so the other idea that
comes out here that I think is very
important for thinking about innovation
is the size of the collective brain the
more interconnected and the larger
populations are the more we expect there
to be fancy tools technology and
adaptive behavioral repertoires and
that's because we we don't think so much
as individuals we think as groups so let
me just show you one piece of evidence
here this is a study done by the
anthropologist Michele Cline and Rob
Boyd and what they did is they went back
to the early ethnographies for a bunch
of
societies in this pacific-10 and they
found good records in these societies
for marine foraging technology so they
coded up the information and analyze the
see if larger or more populous islands
had and fancier tools and you can see
here on these plots that this is a log
scale so larger populations had more
tools for marine foraging and those
tools tended to be more complex so this
is a measure of tool complexity so more
tools and more complex tools they also
looked at contacts because although the
islands provide a nice way to decide
what a population is the islands are
interconnected and there are sailing
between the islands in those times but
the low contact islands tend to be below
the line which means if you're low
contact is suppressing your fanciness of
your technology and if you're a high
contact you're above the line so this
shows both size and interconnectedness
affected the toolkits of Polynesians or
people in Oceania now this is important
when we sometimes paleoanthropologists
will try to read the cognitive
complexity of ancient human species by
looking at how fancy their tools are big
mistake so you wouldn't judge Hawaiians
to be genetically cognitively more
sophisticated than people from Manaus
these are part of the same Austronesian
expansion this is relatively recent
human history but because we think as
collective brains different populations
who are genetically indistinguishable
cognitively can produce quite different
forms of technology now this is just a
correlational study so we wanted to see
if we could get a grip on the grip on
this in a psychology lab so this is a
project I did with Michael mu thru
Krishna at the University of British
Columbia and we created a kind of micro
society so we gave the undergraduates a
task to use a complex image editing
program to reap to recreate this image
that was a thing they had to recreate
they had a time limit they got paid cash
for their performance so how similar
their thing was to the image and they
got paid for the performance of their
students and then the key thing is there
were two different treatments so in this
treatment the teacher in one generation
would pass down their information only
to one other individual and it was then
linear for ten generations and the other
group
this generation can learn from anybody
in this generation and they can see them
all and see what they did whereas these
guys can only see one so after you did
the task at your time-limit you wrote up
to two pages to pass down to your
student remember you would be paid if
your student did well and so the next
generation would get the product
whatever the model made which would give
them a measure of how good the model did
because they can compare it to the
target as well as the the models
write-up so the cultural transmission in
this case this is a quick look at the
results so this is ten generations and
this is the skill or the ability to use
this complex image editing program to
match the target so when there was only
one model to look at you can see this
group initially in the first generation
did well but then it goes nowhere and
they're not able to generate greater
skill but when you can access more of
the models you're more interconnected
the cumulative process kicks in and the
in the final generation these guys are
two to three times more skilled than the
earlier generation now remember subjects
are randomly assigned to these groups
there's no intelligence difference
between these groups this is just the
product of this social interaction okay
now we like this is that I presented
this particular experiment because you
can actually see the results so these
are the the actual images that people
made and this is generation 1 down to
generation 10 so you can see in the 5
model case things did not go well here
in round one I'm not sure what this is
and things did not go well in round 2
since I don't know what that is but then
this guy gets it and then these guys get
it and then they start fixing it up and
things go so by the time you get to this
last generation the worst person in
generation 10 is better than the best
person when they're only receiving one
one transmission so that shows the
importance of inter connecting now I
think this reaches back deep into human
evolutionary history and one of the
things that the key moment which is
actually probably a really long period
of time was when humans cross this
Rubicon and our cumin and our culture
became cumulative because that's when
the interaction of genes and culture
really kicks in so once you get
cumulative cultural evolution you get
increasingly fancy tools
cooking tracking techniques and then the
game is for genetic evolution to build
brains that are not better at doing
those things but better at acquiring
those things by a cultural learning
acquiring organizing storing and maybe
even retransmitting this valuable
information but the thing is once brains
get better genetically at doing that
then culture just revs up even more and
it generates clothing and shelter and
medicinal plant knowledge and even
fancier tools now the genetic side is
like the only game in town is learning
figuring out how to be a better cultural
learner because once culture is
cumulative the stuff in the minds of the
previous generation is way better than
anything you could figure out on your
own by individually interacting with the
environment so you've got to be an
obligate cultural learner and the better
you do it the better you're going to do
because you're going to be able to get
fancy tools from one guy medicinal
plants from another guy shelter building
from the best shelter builder and it can
aggregate and recombine now of course in
the human lineage it looks like our
brains hit the stops so so primates are
the only mammal where the head size of
the baby is larger than the whole it can
fit through so brains shrunk down into
sort of cans and slid through there
babies are born premature compared to
other primates that's because you got to
get that big-headed baby out of there so
selection has done all that it can it
actually twist the female pelvis a
little bit to help that so that's hit
the stops but of course cultural
evolution continues to spiral and
accumulate more and more information one
of the first things that I think might
have happened is a division of labor so
not everybody can know everything once
there's so much information so a
division of information between males
and females is the foundation for the
division of labor
now specialize in some really hard to
learn things female specialize in other
hard to learn things and then of course
later we have external storage and books
and then the internet that's a quick
summary
okay now this is the the products of
Jean cultural evolution are going to
shape our physiology by our anatomy and
psychology so the recurrent features of
the environments that we faced over
human evolutionary history are heavily
influenced by these cultural products so
this is the output the cultural
adaptations and these are going to be
cultural things and these are going to
be genetic things so the first example I
want to give you as an easy one to
understand or the easiest one to
understand so if you look and you
compare human anatomy in physiology to
that of other primates you find that
humans have strangely small teeth we
have small stomachs and we have short
colons this makes good sense if you
realize we're a primate who eats cooked
food we invented fire there's an
argument about this but let's say a
million years ago this allowed us to
cook this means our food comes in
predigested this releases the selection
pressure on having big intestines and a
large stomach and big strong jaws and
muscles that reach up to the top of our
head we can get rid of all that extra
baggage and just cook our food the thing
about fire and cooking though is it's
highly cultural if I was to take all of
you up to cottage country and say you
know start a fire with no technology
most of you would struggle to start a
fire just from some instinct wouldn't
probably wouldn't fire up so you we have
to really depend on cultural know how to
do that but we've been doing that for so
long that it's altered our physiology
and the length of our intestines our
colons another fun one is my colleague
Dan Lieberman has argued that we're the
running species we have all these
adaptations from literally toe to head
that show that we're really good at
long-distance running and human
hunter-gatherers can chase down
antelopes
because the Antelope collapses from heat
exhaustion before a person will one of
the things we have is we store energy
and our arches we also have a nuchal
ligament behind our head that allows our
trunk to twist independent of our bodies
that we see in other running animals but
not in primates another cool feature is
we're have a clean sweat glands all over
our body and these pump out water that
is over our body that cools us as we run
so it gives us a vapid of cooling that
we don't see nearly
to this degree in other species the
interesting thing about that is if you
look at that system as an engineer
you're like elegant beautiful but
there's a big flaw there's no water tank
there's nothing to fuel the big sweating
system that's supposed to do all the
cooling but if you look at how
persistent hunters in small-scale
hunting and gathering societies do this
they use cultural technology they use
ostrich eggs or skins or they have
knowledge about where roots are they
contain water or trees that contain
water or they know to look in other
certain places to find water so this is
a gene-culture co-evolution airy package
that explains a whole bunch of features
of our anatomy but only makes sense if
you have cultural products that are hard
to figure out to start with now I'll
just mention two others of these so when
you study little kids you finally
immediately start making a distinction
between artifacts and other kinds of
things both living and also non living
on artifacts this is a distinction we
don't see in other primates so it looks
like we're primed to assume there are
artifacts and tools in the world you
wouldn't get that unless you'd had
artifacts and tools from which your
cognition has to respond genetically and
then finally my last one and this is
what a the center section of the book is
about is this notion of self
domestication so once you have cultural
transmission you can transmit not only
behaviors but the standards by which you
judge others and that means you can have
social norms where if you violate the
group agreement the group rules you get
punished you get a bad reputation
you can't find mates you can't find
marriage partners and that then begins
to shape the species so it's self
domestication we become more docile more
social more rule-following in a way we
don't see other species we actually have
many of the features of a domesticated
animal although most investigator will
animal brains shrink and ours expanded
so there is that that one difference
okay so I just want to I'm going to do
this slide very briefly and just say
that one of the cool ways that culture
can one of the cool things about culture
is it can make us smarter a lot of the
reason we're getting smarter from age
two and a half up is because we're
getting more and more concepts and tools
that are products of long term
evolutionary processes things like these
tools and screws and springs haven't
always existed but once you grow up in a
world with them you can solve new
problems with them and it makes us
smarter I can say more about that and
question and answer if you want so I
want to close here by asking the
question why do we care so why does it
matter what human nature is or what kind
of animal are we are what the secret of
our success is and I think this is an
important question that has big
implications for how we do institutional
design and policy design because it's
often unrecognized but other disciplines
have at their core assumptions about
human nature and the problem is is that
most of the time these assumptions go
unintelligent is apply a relatively well
has is based on an enlightenment
philosophy kind of filtered through 19th
century philosophers and that's the
assumptions about human nature that we
have and we know that many of those
assumptions are wrong and misleading so
one of the things I wanted to do with
this book was try to say let's build a
new foundation for the social and
behavioral sciences that's rooted in
what we know about human evolutionary
biology but take seriously the unique
nature of our species and this will
allow us to do better institutional
design and better policy design rather
than having disciplines based on
unintelligible you mean nature right
is now my great pressure to invite to
junior fellows colleagues from Massey
College to join us here on stage and to
join in the process of asking questions
to and learning from our guest speaker
tonight
rosemary Martin is the second-year PhD
with Shannon McAuley in the department
of ecology and evolutionary biology
having just transferred from a master's
rosemarys research focuses on how winter
environments affect survival phenology
population dynamics and interspecific
interactions in freshwater aquatic in
vertebrae community
she has mostly worked with ordinates
both lab and field settings
Rosemarie would you come up and join me
on stage now
Devin Ward is a first year PhD student
with Ben seola and Mary Silcox and
evolutionary anthropology she's
currently expanding her research she
began during her MPhil at the University
of Cambridge examining the causes and
consequences of morphological variation
in the modern human inner ear for a
structure with a very conserved purpose
there is much unexplained variation in
our species with the potential to relate
to many variables including gestational
health Devin also has extensive field
experience and has worked on act of
archaeological projects in Gibraltar and
Italy please join us on stage
so the purpose of this part of the
evening
not only to illustrate how profoundly
bright the junior fellows of Massey
College are but more importantly to
engage in a way that produces questions
that our guests can answer and hopefully
generate some interest amongst all of
you and asking further questions in the
time that we have together or either one
of you ready to ask a question and
eventually we will open the facilitate
the discussion section of this evening
we're going to start off some with some
questions that Devon then I have
prepared so without further ado Devon
will ask the first question into the
last European explorer files what about
you taking an outdoor survival course
life is traveling around by dugout canoe
and amazonian so I got a sense I learned
a bunch of stuff from the macho Ganga
about how to find food and one of the
things that was shocking during that
experience was that I was an Eagle Scout
and so I spent a lot of time doing
wilderness survival and I was just
amazing how inept I felt when I was
around the macho game because they just
have this body of knowledge that so one
of the things about being an
anthropologist is you always feel when
you're doing fieldwork like you're the
dumb guy in the community because you
don't know how to do anything useful
okay I felt that way in the Senate for a
while in your book you discussed how
music and especially ritual for taste
participation through music acts to
build cooperative behavior but more
recently many genres of music have their
own subcultures that may crash with
mainstream tastes for example hey Dad
classical music sung in the
go listen to hardcore rock and so what
is the effect of rebellious subcultures
that may cause division rather than
unity in the evolution of our human
societies sure I think the way you want
to think about this so so just as
background in the audience in one of the
chapters I make the case that ritual is
one of the ways in which humans build
social bonds so you see this across
human societies and for I don't know
certainly decades probably a century
anthropologists have making been making
the case that when humans and they're
thinking of small-scale societies in
this case participate in rituals it
bonds a community together so you can
find ethnographic description after
ethnographic description it'll say the
the harmony in the community is greatly
increased after they did a big ritual
and they rebuilt the bonds and they
danced in synchrony or they shared a
experience together and so now in
psychology in the last 10 years or so
psychologists have been to take the
untaken the elements of rituals and
asking the question does this element
increase cooperation or sociality or
make people feel more bonded so one
thing that psychologists have done work
on is synchrony so if you March people
around in synchrony which is interesting
when you think about military drill when
you March people are unsink repeat
they'll be more cooperative in a public
goods game a game where you have to give
money to a group project and you have
the potential of free ride and be
selfish people are less selfish in these
experiments and they also report feeling
more bonded with the other individuals
or with when they've engaged in
synchronous activity and then you can
pull out music and music seems to have
at least according to some studies an
independent effect from synchrony and
then there's even rituals throughout
this small scale societies in which you
experience something terrifying together
so these are classic rites of passage
and that seems to really bond the people
who Co experienced the terrifying events
together together so one of the ways
psychologists have studied this is by
looking at people who had traumatic
experiences and were together this seems
to create this brand the brothers effect
but in many societies the society
actually has a ritual that terrifies the
and so they bond together and it's often
done with people from other groups so it
creates enduring bonds with men who you
know you're going to get old together
but they'll be in a different band but
when you see each other you'll have this
kind of bond so the way to think about
the different groups doing different
things is this is just the fuel for
cultural evolution so different groups
come up with different ways of doing
rituals and nobody really knows what a
good ritual is going to be like with
this what the keys are to our psychology
that's going to cause this bonding but
by creating lots of variation you can
gradually improve and home the loop ways
in which ritual can get inside of our
heads and build bonds between people so
you mentioned these subcultures it's
worth pointing out that both
Christianity and Mormonism were
subcultures that found a way to spread I
think Joseph was just explained the
importance of the high table at Massey
College but that's actually one element
so eating together seems to build some
sort of solid or there's a big there's a
reason why we decide to share meals all
the time advantageous ideas that can
spread due to a cultural evolution in
selection but I'm also curious about the
the maladaptive ideas that may spread
and sometimes those may even be
consciously spread and so you mentioned
suicide quickly in your tacos when they
give you an expand a bit more on how
some of these disadvantageous ideas
spread yeah so that's one of the
interesting parts about cultural
evolution is the idea is is that these
mechanisms the biases we have are on
average examples but you're essentially
making a bet that it's going to tend to
triangulate you in on the right idea it
means that a bunch of the time you're
going to get either neutral things or
even maladaptive things kind of
freeriding the law the other interesting
area of research is it's under some
conditions you can have adaptive
learning mechanisms that can steer you
off and just and create something very
maladaptive under certain conditions so
one example is
real emphasis on prestige can do this
probably is important in our own society
that prestige can be amplified by the
media and then cause people to go down
paxil and otherwise go to but some of
the better studied cases are is their
case in Micronesia and in Micronesia
people began attending to and giving
prestige to very good gamblers and soon
people began to compete to see who could
grow the biggest annum and this cause
meant to focus on throwing the biggest
game but soon the ants got so big that
they were fibrous and inedible and so
they meant that men would spend lots of
resources to grow these giant yams that
nobody could eat and so you can see that
this is an adaptive thing which was
improving our farming practices the cue
of having a big hand became so important
that the yams grew to the point of which
they weren't edible you can see that we
just say we do have two microphones one
on each side
anybody here this evening would like to
get the microphone to pose a question
please be free to do so
can I ask a question while our colleague
is moving to the microphone
what does government do with these
insights what what a thoughtful
government seeking to appreciate the
nuance and the different kinds of
learning that you've talked about Oh
what areas of its policy what it
shouldn't affect most construction so my
wife does public health so I have
something I feel like I have some
insight into the field and one of the
things that's very hard to get out of
people in public health heads is that
education matters so they always have
this idea that we're going to teach
people to use latrines or to wash their
hands and once they get this information
will start guilty and this seems to have
failed time after time and I've always
heard her to write a paper on showing
all the different ways and this has
failed so it happens that this is my
example of how this could inform policy
but the British government decided they
wanted to try to convince women to do
more
screenings for these genetic variants
that cause breast cancer so they started
a program in January of 2013 and the
program was going along and maybe they
saw a few bumps a little bit of increase
in women going for the screenings and
then Angelina Jolie
he wrote op-ed in the New York Times in
which he discussed her decision to get a
double mastectomy because she had this
very and the day after that the call
lines flooded in New Zealand and
Australia and the US and Canada with
women who wanted to get screened for the
gene and this we know unloaded this then
resulted eventually in enough lots of
surgeries being scheduled and the great
rate of calls remain elevated until
November or December of that year so she
elevated the rate for the whole year and
Britain is fun because we can see that
this campaign of information did almost
nothing and Angelina is one author a
powerful prestigious person with access
to the media you know basically solve
the problem doesn't word out lots of
wind cut screens and lots of the cases
of cancer will probably be perfect so
that's a case where we have this kind of
rational notion that if people are
well-informed we can get them to change
behavior but it's actually about a piece
of cultural life which raises the issue
of celebrity both positive and negative
which is another kind of yeah the
advertising industry has figured this
one out yes ma'am you mentioned briefly
the role of language that is symbolic
communication as a driver of an
adaptability and your thesis seems to be
that we should perhaps look more at
sociability as proportionately a greater
driver of our great success in it as a
species and adaptability but I'm
thinking of other species of primates
most especially bonobos which are known
to be highly social and it's been argued
that they are even more social as you
know our you know the third you know
where the third chimp you know as the
second chimp
then we are there are other mammals such
as meerkats that are intricately and
very highly social nonetheless the level
of invention and adaptability is not
comparative and might not some
evolutionists argue that our acquisition
of highly evolved language that is
symbolic usage and of course other
animals
most particularly other mammals have
symbolic communication not just you know
chemical communication etc etc but you
know quite complex often methods of
symbolic communication like you know
walls other other primates nonetheless
we seem to have evolved symbolic
communication in a you know at a
comparing fantastic level and so in
let's say a debate about which might be
more important sociability or language
acquisition and whether or not the
language acquisition or the Sochi
ability might be in gold's term a
spandrel or not is there not a very
great debate there so let me make sure I
got your question right so you're
wondering about the place of language in
the story we're just at the weighting of
the important language versus
sociability but some of the debate
around that and I know that there's a
very intense debate around you know
what's the driver of what is of a
spandrel that is an accidental
acquisition you know yeah so my approach
to that is to say that blank so I
emphasize tools and technology and in
this talk in the book I laid that out at
the beginning but then I bring in
language I see language is just another
domain of culture so you got tools you
got language you got institutions and
languages actually work I mean we learn
language using some of the same cultural
learning mechanisms and cultural
learning biases languages accumulate
larger populations have larger
vocabularies more phonemes fancier
grammar so it seems to fit all the same
patterns of cultural evolution as the
tools do so the story is that language
is nothing special it's a it's a
community so the chapter is called
communicative tools with rules so you're
trying to solve the communication
problem and you're gradually rapid
ratcheting up a repertoire of these
share tools for which we can communicate
with I'm going to let Devin and rosemary
ask another question and I'll come back
to the southern question
the connection and an exposure to other
cultures has increased which increases
the potential for horizontal
transmission of these cultural practices
and ideas but also potentially decouples
these cultures from the historical
context in which they were developed and
the genetic fashions in which they
evolved so do you think that this is
more likely to lead to our ability to
select and integrate and adapt to new
cultures or will it lead to more likely
to lead to a tendency to kind of grow
more conservative and stick to what we
we've grown up with yeah so my view is
that anything that is going to
interconnect more and more people is
going to lead to faster rates of
adaptive cultural evolution or
innovation even the rate at which people
engage in horizontal transition seems to
be much higher in modern Western
societies and in small-scale societies
where there's more parent-child relation
so all there should fertilise amounts of
recombination
although I think that the point you made
early in the question is important we
are losing a lot of repertoires of
knowledge when we lose languages and
cultures because there are whole ways of
say constructing a grammar or kinds of
ways of carving up the world that when
you lose a language in a culture you
don't get to see any more so those could
be powerful and fertilizing but I think
the lesson of history is that languages
that prove to our lives are technologies
that improve travel and increase
communication I'm just going to ask our
colleague across the way and then I'm
gonna come right back to you yes sir
certainly I think we're gonna come
around to this sooner or later so I'm
gonna I'm going to be the one to do it
as the case study I'm sure everyone is
dying to know what your thoughts might
be on how this would apply to the
current u.s. election clarify that frame
that little bit for you
I mean what
listening carefully to what you said and
I'm listing off some of the things that
don't seem to fit for example we have
candidate kind of a maverick candidate
that breaks all kinds of social norms
but still seems to be rewarded doesn't
demonstrate confidence like he's not
going with the sharp arrows that are
getting all the break and also he
doesn't seem to be a good match for you
know his own group like the Republican
Party you know that in terms of policies
and the things that he says yep getting
enormous traction we're seeing enormous
traction in the polls and the rallies
and sort of in profile and of course you
gotta be wondering what is going on in
there is it something you know are there
cultural cues or their color idea or
does this cultural evolution inform this
and help understand because you know
pundits are at a total loss
so I have a collaborator in psychology
professor at the University British
Columbia named Jeff Tracy so we decided
to videotape the debate between Hillary
Clinton and Donald Trump and while one
of the ideas I developed in the book is
that humans have two kinds of status
both of which can be important for
leadership a status based on prestige or
your thought to have knowledge and
confidence and one based on dominance
and so we're analyzing the ethology and
the speaking styles using a coding
system that we developed years ago to
distinguish dominance and prestige I
don't know what the answer is going to
be yet but it'll be interesting to see
if they're actually using these two
different avenues of status which we
found in lots of other experiments but
the one thing I was wondering and I this
is purely you know a speculation I
haven't had to study this question I
don't I I think that Trump may appeal to
wide breadth of the electorate cuz it
feels like some people they know like he
has characteristics in defense and
mannerisms that go very much with lots
of subcultures in the US and of course
he is a billionaire which he likes to
point out so it could be that he's
tapping these various kind of cute
you're asking me to go way way way out
of my area thank you very much and ma'am
you've been very patient and please ask
your second question and my second
question is with regards to an ongoing
and very intense debate about whether
level selection happens at the
individual level the so-called selfish
gene versus group selection you know
with the group selection Theory having
been under intense attack would you
place your theory in the group selection
let's say end of things and how would
you defend your theory against those who
would argue that it's individual
selection you know the so-called selfish
gene you know that whole conversation
sure so the the case that a group
selection debate is a complex of doing
so in the book is this is actually in
the footnotes I make the case that in
humans should be effective intergroup
competitions they having worked
between-groups is unlikely to have any
effect on human genetic evolution
because we know this from studies our
loss of societies that when one who
conquers they'll often kill all the
males and take the women as wives or as
concubines and so there's a big flow of
genes between the groups this is going
to erase any differences between the
groups and leave only individual
selection operating now that doesn't
work at the cultural level so the case
the book makes is that while judge while
group selection is unlikely to be an
important force in genetic evolution for
humans cultural evolution doesn't have
that same problem defusing the
differences between groups so when
hydrants come into a cultural group they
have to learn the local norms and even
if the adults can't learn the local arm
so their kids do whereas if genetic
migrants come into a group they have the
genes they brought from the other group
and their kids have the genes so the
nature of the inherited systems makes
these quite quite different dynamics so
with the book I make the case that that
cultural evolution has favored
institutions and sets of norms and
marriage systems and rituals that
increasingly are give people the ability
to cooperate and intergenic groups lead
to larger collective brain and so this
has been a cultural evolutionary process
now in the wake they're still individual
genetic evolution has to adapt to this
world that was built by cultural groups
or so the last three questioners are at
the Michael I'm gonna ask them to
proceed and ask you to put your
questions on your hands Joe to answer
all three of them if I may say so sir I
good evening I'm a junior fellow from
Massey as well my name's Peter thank you
very much for the talk so one of the
ideas I brought out was the cumulative
brain and you used the undergraduate
experiment and the other pattern from
UBC to illustrate that as well as the
island one appears as there seem to be a
correlation with the number of members
within this cumulative ring and the
success of how they're able to propagate
and and create innovation so when you
looking at the structure of high high
income countries were Morse who seems to
be more successful and better at
innovation compared to the lower
middle-income countries do you feel the
that pattern still holds
and if if not you feel it's more inside
just numbers there's more about the
advocacy to which they can utilize
certain framework to better record of
that yes ma'am so what does this mean
for future labor and finally can you
because of globalization and the
prevalence of it at this point um would
you be able to apply theories of
academia epidemiology to cultural
transmission and social planning
question so I was just I'm wondering at
what point of technological development
do you feel that we might outstrip our
capacity to adapt evolutionarily you can
work backwards if it's easier job there
was so I think maybe this answers to
maybe starts to address two of the
questions which is one of the things you
got to deal with when you're thinking
about innovation and increasingly
complex societies is not just the size
of the population but the division of
labor because in order to make that next
advance you have to have a certain
amount of it's really the population of
the knowledge frontier that's capable of
taking the next step so for example if
you look at US cities the larger the
city the more innovation you get from
the city and that's parked in a
population size but it's also in part
due to the number of different
specializations you have in the city so
you just have more different experts
than the city that can interact and
create
so this is relevant to the question of
developing societies because you got to
get a certain population a certain
community of people to the knowledge
frontier in order to allow people with
different expertise to interact so my
colleague at Harvard Roberta Fieldhouse
Ricardo Hausmann studies this and he
typically cities add they expand the
division of labor in a very systematic
way so there's certain kinds of things
are not going to have until you have a
whole bunch of other and you can't take
the next step until you've accumulated
so I think that answers some of the
questions so there's no greater sign of
a coherent and competent intellect than
being able to admit that he doesn't know
I think you will agree with me that
we've had a remarkable reflection and
intellectual engagement around some of
the core foundational issues of how
society has come about the choices we
have made the roots of civilization and
humanity and all the other linkages that
are fundamental to getting along in this
world that we share and I would like you
to join with me in expressing our
appreciation to both our guest speaker
and the two junior fellows who have put
him through his paces here
[Applause]
Masey college is really honored to be a
partner with c far in these undertakings
we think it speaks to the core premise
of interdisciplinarity both institutions
and the role that both institutions play
not only in finding solutions to tough
questions but having the courage to work
with people who actually have the
ability to ask the right questions and
that's what we are celebrating here
tonight or honored to do it thank you
all very much
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you